you should tell the story of the rose oh
okay
well um so i was driving down the
ventura freeway one day and a song comes
on the radius
fabulous danny o'keefe song called
magdalena that was a big hit for leo
sayer
and there was a verse a line in there
where he says
your love is like a razor my heart is
just a scar and i
just thought that was such a good line
but i kept thinking as i was driving and
thinking i don't think love is like a
razor what do i think love is
and all of a sudden that weird sensation
and i know
you know it where somebody pried open
the top of your head and starts pouring
words into the top of your head
and i ran home and i automatic wrote i
ran into my app i ran into my piano i
picked up my pencil
and i just started automatic writing the
lyric was just there
in about maybe 10 minutes maybe 15
minutes
of course that's you know time may have
truncated the
amount of effort and then i played it
for george because i always played my
songs for george and he
said you just wrote a standard and i
said don't be silly no one's ever going
to hear it but
you know you and me and michelle and my
three friends and he said something is
going to happen to that song
and so i had it i sang it occasionally
and then a couple of years later
michelle and her writing partner karen
had heard there was this film coming
around called the rose
and for some reason they were looking
for outsourced material rather than
having one person write all the music
for the movie back in the days when
there were songs in movies
um and they said you've got the song
called the rose you want us to submit it
for you and i didn't
i didn't know anything about submitting
songs it wasn't like
you know i don't know how to get a song
cut and i said sure
and they sent it to the producers and
the producers hated it
they thought it was stupid they thought
it was a hymn and they were looking for
rock and roll and they just said i don't
think so but the guy was the music
supervisor
paul rothschild who had been janice
joplin's md
he said there's something in this song
so he played it for the director
and then he mailed it to bet and bet
said i wanted it
i want it in the show so it was in the
film
and then of course there was the whole
thing about who should sing it her or me
and thank god they decided she should be
the one to sing it because it
it was her first big hit her first big
anthem hit which was great and sold a
lot more than it would have sold if it
was me
and then all of a sudden people started
thinking
of me as a songwriter and i just kept
saying i'm not a songwriter i'm an
actress this is my hobby i'm not a
songwriter i'm an actress
my husband finally said don't you think
you should take responsibility
for this gift what's paying the mortgage
what you know this is you have a gift
and you have a responsibility to it